you've written the following
i've had the experience countless times
making love watching a sunset listening
to music
feeling the breeze that i would sign up
for this
whole life and all of its pains just to
experience
this exact moment this is a kind of
worldless
knowing it's the most important and real
truth
i know that experience itself is
infinitely meaningful
and pain is temporary and seen
clearly even the suffering is filled
with beauty
i have experienced countless lives worth
of moments
worthy of life such an unreasonable
fortune a few words of gratitude from
you
beautifully written is there some
beautiful moments
now you have uh experience countless
lives worth of those moments
but there are some things that uh
if you could uh in your darker moments
you can go to to relive to remind
yourself that the whole
ride is worthwhile maybe skip the making
love part we don't
know about that
i mean i i feel i feel unreasonably
fortunate that
it is a such a humongous
list because i mean i feel fortunate to
have
like had exposure to practices and
philosophies and way of seeing things
that makes me see things that way
so i can take responsibility for seeing
things in that way
and not taking for granted really
wonderful things but i can't take
credit for being exposed to the
philosophies that even gave me that
possibility
um you know it's not just
with my wife it's with
every person who i really love when
we're talking i look at their face
i in the context of a conversation feel
overwhelmed by
how lucky i am to get to know them and
like that there's never been someone
like them in all of history
and there never will be again and they
might be gone tomorrow i might be gone
tomorrow and like i get this moment with
them
and when you take in the uniqueness of
that fully in the beauty of it it's
overwhelmingly beautiful
and i remember the first time
i did a big dose of mushrooms and
i was looking at a tree for a long time
and i was just crying with overwhelming
how beautiful the tree was and it was a
tree outside the front of my house that
i'd walk by a million times and never
looked at like this and it wasn't the
dose
of mushrooms where i was hallucinating
like where the tree was purple yeah like
the tree still looked like
if i had to describe it says green it
has leaves looks like this
but it was way [ __ ] more beautiful
like
like capturing than it normally was and
i'm like why is it so beautiful if i
would describe it the same way
and i realized i had no thoughts taking
me anywhere else
yeah like what it seemed like the
mushrooms were doing was just actually
shutting the narrative off that would
have me be distracted so i could really
see the tree
and then i'm like [ __ ] when i get off
these mushrooms i'm going to practice
seeing the tree
because it's always that beautiful and i
just miss it and so i
practice being with it and quieting the
rest of the mind and then being like wow
and and if it's not mushrooms like
people have peak experiences
where they'll see life and how
incredible it is it's always there
it's funny that i had this exact same
experience
on quite a lot of mushrooms just sitting
alone and looking at a tree and exactly
as you described it
appreciating the undistorted beauty of
it
and it's funny to me that here's two
humans very different with very
different journeys
or at some moment in time both looking
at a tree like idiots for hours
and just in awe and and happy to be
alive and yeah
uh even just that moment alone is is
worth living for but you did say
humans and uh we have a moment together
as two humans
and you mentioned shots that's uh well i
have to ask what uh what
what are we looking at when i went to go
get a smoothie before coming here i got
you a keto smoothie that you didn't want
because you're not just keto but fasting
but i saw the thing with you and your
dad where you did uh
shots together yeah and this place
happened to have shots
of um ginger turmeric cayenne
juice of some kind and so i was some
himalayan i didn't necessarily plan it
for being on the show
i just broke it well we can we can do it
that way i think we should we shall uh
we shall toast like heroes daniel it's a
huge
tube what do we toast to we toast to
this moment
this this this unique moment that we get
to share together
i'm very grateful to be here in this
moment with you and uh
yeah i'm grateful that you invited me
here we met for the first time
and i will never be the same for the
good and the bad the i am
that is really interesting that feels
way healthier than the vodka
my dad and i were drinking so i feel
like a better man already daniel this is
one of the best conversations i've ever
had
i can't wait to have many more likewise
this is uh
it's been an amazing experience thank
you for wasting all your time today i
want to say
in terms of what you're mentioning about
like the
that you work in machine learning and
the optimism that wants to look at the
issues but wants to
look at how this increased technological
power could be applied to solving them
and that even thinking about the
broadcast of like
can i help people understand issues
better and help organize them
like fundamentally you're you're
oriented like wikipedia
what i see to really try to tend to the
information commons
without another agentic interest
distorting it
and for you to be able to get guys like
lee smolin and roger penrose and like
the the greatest
thinkers of that are alive and you know
have them on the show and most people
would never be exposed to them and talk
about it in a way that people can
understand
uh i think it's an incredible service i
think you're doing great work
so i was really happy to hear from you
thank you
you